la cour d'accusation de la cour d'appel
de nancy réunis pour décider du sort de
christine villemin c'est le dernier
épisode judiciaire de cette affaire
les magistrats doivent maintenant
décider de la suite à donner au dossier
d'instruction sur place à nancy
marcel trillât conciliabule à huit clos
entrantes de loi à la chambre
d'accusation de la cour d'appel de nancy
l'enjeu pour le président voxel berger
et ses deux assesseurs le sort de
christine villemin
renvoi aux assises ou non lieu deux
clans en face de m lombard maîtres
lagrange partie civile pour les
grands-parents et les oncles de grégory
l'enfant assassiné au tour de m garot le
clan christine villemin bien décider de
son côté à gagner du temps au coeur du
débat d'aujourd'hui les pièces du
dossier accumulés depuis deux ans par un
absent le juge d'instruction lambert qui
a annoncé récemment sa décision de se
mettre en congé sabbatique à partir de
janvier prochain
dans un mémoire de 297 pages déposée il
ya quinze jours la défense énumère les
innombrables fautes de procédure
susceptible d'après elle d'entraîner la
nullité de nombreuses pièces du dossier
d'instruction le procureur général
règles bolets écarte la plupart de ces
irrégularités qu'il juge sans importance
sauf une lors de la reconstitution du 30
octobre 1985
le juge lambert enregistré les
déclarations de plusieurs témoins
importants mais en négligeant de leur
faire signer leurs dépositions
c'est un cas de nullité incontournable
il est donc probable que la chambre
d'accusation décrète un supplément
d'enquêté et une nouvelle reconstitution
des faits et gestes de christine
villemin
le soir du crime